nothing's changed about our policy
we have some breaking news and we're
hearing off an ongoing serious incident
in Nottingham that's in the UK these are
the live pictures from the scene right
now the latest pictures excuse me let's
bring in Nadeem Baba he's joining us on
the phone from London so Nadeem it's
being described as a quote major
incident but what do we know so far
well there are still details coming
through but the police in Nottingham
that City in the Midlands here in
England say that fair currently at an
ongoing serious incident now on social
media people have been posting uh photos
a video of main roads in the city center
of Nottingham closed off um cordoned off
with blue and white
tape and the uh the local tram network
uh has said that um it has suspended
operations and has asked people to stay
away from the city center there was I've
seen myself on social media a photo of
what looks like a tram uh that has been
derailed but I can't actually verify
that to say where it was taken or when
um so people will be uh extremely
anxious to find out more details because
not just uh the uh the transport network
but the police themselves have called it
a major incident without actually uh
giving any hint of why uh it's of
concern uh it's only really started in
the last couple of hours but this is a
major population Center probably people
traveling through it as well as uh
within it to get to work and the like uh
so we're waiting to find out a bit more
okay Nadeem we'll let you go for now
thank you so much for bringing us that
update from London reports of a incident
taking place in Nottingham once we get
more information we will bring it to you
right here on Al Jazeera
well lava has started flowing down myON
volcano in the Philippines prompting the
government there to issue evacuation or